what we're going to do in this video is
explore how experimental probability
should get closer and closer to
theoretical probability as we conduct
more and more experiments or as we
conduct more and more trials this is
often referred to as the law of large
numbers if we only have a few experiment
it's very possible that our experimental
probability could be different than our
theoretical probability or even very
different but as we have many many more
experiments thousands millions billions
of experiments the probability that the
experimental and the theoretical
probabilities are very different goes
down dramatically but let's get an
intuitive sense for it this right over
here is a simulation created by
Macmillan USA I'll provide the link as
an annotation and what it does is it
allows us to simulate many coin flips
and figure out the proportion that our
heads so right over here we can decide
if we want our coin to be fair or not
right now it says that we have a 50%
probability of getting a heads we can
make it unfair by changing this but I'll
stick with the 50% probability we want
to show that on this graph here we can
plot it and what this says is at a time
how many tosses do we want to take so
let's say let's just start with 10
tosses so what this is going to do is
take ten simulated flips of coins with
each one having a 50% chance of being
heads and then as we flip we're going to
see our total proportion that our heads
so let's just talk through this together
so starting to toss and so what's going
on here after 10 flips so as you see the
first flip actually came out heads and
if you wanted to say what's your
experimental probability after that one
flip you'd say well with only one
experiment I got one head so it looks
like 100% were heads but in the second
flip it looks like it was a tails
because now the proportion that was
heads after two flips was 50% but in the
third flip it looks like it was tails
again because now only one out of three
or 33% of the flips have resulted in
heads now by the fourth flip
we got a heads again getting us back to
50th percentile now the fifth lift it
looks like we got another heads and so
now we have three out of five or 60%
being hit and so the general takeaway
here is when you have one two three four
five or six experiments it's completely
plausible that your experimental
proportion your experimental probability
diverges from the real probability and
this even continues all the way until we
get to our ninth or tenth tosses but
what happens if we do way more tosses so
now I'm going to do another well let's
just do another 200 tosses and see what
happens so I'm just going to keep
tossing here and you can see Wow look at
this there was a big run getting a lot
of heads right over here and then it
looks like there's actually a run of
getting a bunch of tails right over here
then a little run of heads tails and
another run of heads and notice even
after 215 tosses our experimental
probability has still is still
reasonably different than our
theoretical probability so let's do
another 200 and see if we can converge
these over time and what we're seeing in
real time here should be the law of
large numbers as our number of tosses
get larger and larger and larger
the probability that these two are very
different goes down and down and down
yes you will get moments where you could
even get ten heads in a row or even 20
heads in a row but over time those will
be balanced by the times where you're
getting disproportionate number of tails
so I'm just going to keep going we're
not almost 800 tosses and you see now we
are converging with now this is we're
going to cross a thousand tosses soon
and you can see that our proportion here
is now fifty-one percent it's getting
close now we're at fifty point six
percent and I could just keep tossing
this is 1,100 we're going to approach
1,200 or 1,300 flips right over here but
as you can see as we get many many many
more flips was actually valuable to see
even after 200 flips that there was a
difference in the proportion between
what we got from the experiment and what
you would theoretically expect but as we
get too many men
more flips now we're at 1210 we're
getting pretty close to 50% of them
turning out head we could keep tossing
it more and more and more what we'll see
is as we get larger and larger and
larger it is likely that we're going to
get closer and closer and closer to 50%
it's not to say that it's impossible
that we diverge again but the likelihood
of diverging gets lower and lower and
lower the more tosses the more
experiments you make